And the correct answer should be No.
If you marked Yes, and you insist on marking Yes--
even though we're going to mark you Wrong--
well, then you probably work on the App Engine Datastore,
and thank you for taking this course.
But for everybody else--myself included--
the answer is No.
You should get very comfortable with the App Engine Datastore
documentation--it's all online, there's a lot of it,
and it's very helpful.
We'll link to it in the course notes and we'll link to it in the homework.
I reference it a lot while I'm even teaching these lectures.
So anyway, get familiar with the docs--there's a lot to know--
and let's move on to the fun part.